kristen and dax talk to me about how
your love of game night uh
turned into uh family game fight
well it's kind of um like a two-parter
one is we played this really silly game
once on
ellen called taste buds macaroni and
cheese no it's a crunchy crunchy apple
oh jesus
christ
sour cream and cheddar they look like
jesus
cheeses
and it was probably the funniest thing
we've ever done on and it was on
accident yeah so we thought how do we do
that how can we harness it because that
was good television and we had a good
time doing it and that's what you're
looking for in your job right someone to
enjoy your services and also enjoy doing
it and we love playing games at home
um and we watch game shows so we were
like you know
why not do a game show but we didn't
want to feel left out so in this one in
family game fight we're playing
with the contestants how intense does
the competition level get
at home when it's just you guys kids are
asleep
well there's fight you know there's big
big fights yeah there's police have
never come but that's a shock to be
honest we have
you know we have had to make a therapy
appointment because like the the
you know fighting over a board game when
you're calling your therapist is sort of
like
maybe we should throw that board game
out
[Applause]
[Music]
and you're hosting together were there
any reservations about
signing up for a job that's going to put
you together more than you have to be
not a one all right this is our favorite
yeah
we've done i don't know maybe four or
five movies of each other's
we've been in each other's tv shows in a
marriage and when you're raising kids
there's so much compromise because he
wants to parent one way i want a parent
one way he wants to go to one restaurant
i want to go to a different but when we
have a shared goal
at work and we play off of each other
really well that just makes us feel more
connected
yeah also you really come to rely on
each other
in a way that reminds you like oh right
i have this amazing human in my life
and uh i get to work with her
i just want to let it sink in because
it's simple he's nice he's nice
did i get that line right that was
written for me i just want to make sure
did i say it right do we need a second
take speaking of everything
who's the most competitive who's the
biggest loser out of the two of you
we're both pretty good losers i will say
i i
i can take a loss i mean it's a bummer
um but i'll never try to make anyone
feel bad and you are an excellent loser
as well thank you so much you're welcome
as far as competitiveness goes it's just
out of ten so
whatever we're both out of ten yeah
who's the best
overall game night contender winner
loser happy to be there enjoying the
game
who's the best at just enjoying game
night before it turns out
when it turns ugly probably probably you
right probably probably you yeah yeah
because she's just into the the
socialness the community
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i like when the
rules are followed and people pay
attention and they're not checking their
phone so yeah those things will creep in
to my uh schools guy are you a house
rules guys of course
yes yes no no we have like we have
debates before the game starts what are
our agreed upon rules
we play it flat fast and lose we make up
our own rules all the time and then we
have to reiterate them to the group
because we don't want anyone anyone
arguing after we don't want any funny
business
claiming some false victory right talk
to me about your
your kids or do they share your
competitive spirit when it comes to
games
they play uno okay they what else that's
pretty much it
yeah they play you know they want to
play spades
uh because we play it about 75 hours a
week
so they're pretty curious and they're
ready to start but it's a pretty
complicated it's a complicated
game and they just don't have the focus
yet
what kind of games do we see on the show
do you have a favorite is there anything
you could tease us with
there's a great game that is both our
favorite and
our most disliked mm-hmm yeah it's a
mean
game it's a bad game it's not friendly
nope uh wrong answers results in a pie
in your face it's called pie rollers
we get a card with a clue on it we have
to say i can get my partner to guess
this
in three clues he says i look at mine i
go i can
i can do it in two and she goes i don't
think he can try it
and then pies piezo fly yeah the celeb
edition
of this show who do you put on there who
does good who does bad who do you think
can handle the stress of the competition
oh not a lot of them i'll tell you that
right now
they hollywood better buckle up but
on this show big time yeah i'm gonna go
ahead and say what i want to see
is a good place versus parenthood
episode oh wow what a brilliant idea
that was anna's idea ellen is executive
producing her show's
ending is there a chance in your
universe
ever that you would entertain a talk
show
either one of you dax i have one that i
love called armchair experts so i'm
pretty
delighted interviewing people on there
i don't think it's for me i don't think
it's for me i've seen the hours that go
into it
and i don't know the attention span i
like to have my fingers in a lot of
different pots
sure sure but whoever takes over i wish
them the best of luck
okay we had to ask because we like
watching you on tv oh
thank you yeah i was looking at her
talking to you
talk to me about gossip girl real quick
you're doing it again back at it
you've gotten so comfortable
[Applause]
[Music]
thinking you're in control we're all
excited
you obviously are excited for this what
can you tease oh yeah well i i mean i
sanded
i signed on real quick i i love the
creators of that show and they've
really brought the show into
the 22 thousands is that this year no
it's a 2021
2021 it's a clunky it's all clunky it's
all clunky but they really brought it up
with like
you know looking at what social media is
doing to us how we follow it how we
don't who's behind it and there's a
twist at the end of episode one that is
pretty amazing and i'm just having a
fun time doing it from this other than
being constantly funny together
what are you getting from this amazing
show
i mean legitimately though now listen
there are games we hate
that we want to call terrorists we want
to call drinkers yeah they they pour
ice cold water on our heads repeatedly
no that's not for us
but there are five or six games that we
actually
really really love playing like when we
hear any of them
we love this one airheads another fun a
word game where people get blasted in
the face with air
yeah if you play it at home it's called
like um one word answer
and you have to try to not get
duplicates get someone to guess the word
they get a huge air cannon in their face
and we're wearing funny wigs and they
fly off and it's
you know guessing games are really
really fun on this show for sure
all right look we look forward to seeing
this we love seeing everything you guys
are both doing uh thanks for having us
thanks for taking the time
yeah thanks so much
you